ich bin sogar auch dagegen ich bin
dagegen den dixie herauszustreichen
seinem einer dunkelhäutigen tochter
möchte ich erklären was es mit dem wort
[ __ ] auf sich hat wenn ich als trans
andersohn mich irgendwo bewerben möchte
bei einer firma und ich sehe auf der
webseite dass die keine lgbt abteilung
kann der börse die abteilung dann
bewerbe ich mich dort nicht sagen ich
möchte aber nicht geändert wir aushalten
habt ihr das gefühl immer sagen zu
dürfen was ihr wollt was ist politisch
korrekt und wie korrekt wollen wir sein
hilft zum beispiel das gender sternchen
dabei klarheit zu schaffen und
gleichberechtigung oder führt es eher zu
mehr bevormundung unsere gäste heute
sind sich in diesen fragen einigermaßen
uneins wie der rest der gesellschaft
auch ich versuche sie mit 13 fragen in
richtung eines kompromisses zu führen
und mal sehen ob das klappt die erste
frage geht wie immer an euch seid ihr
auch manchmal unsicher ob ihr die
richtigen worte verwendet eure meinung
gerne in die kommentare
so wie kommen in runde eins ist eine
schnelle runde noch ohne worte frage
nummer zwei von 13 fragen lautet müssen
wir auch unsere sprache verändern um
unsere gesellschaft zu verändern wenn
ihr sagt ja er ja dann geht ihr bitte
richtung gelb wenn er sagt nicht
unbedingt dann bitte richtung grün
[Musik]
ich glaube dass leute denken wenn ich
die und die sprache verwende oder nicht
verwende
dann bin ich schon auf der guten seite
und das funktioniert nicht
es geht viel weniger um die art wie wir
sprechen als darum was wir tun gender
gerechter sprache ist mir wichtig weil
ich der überzeugung bin dass sprache
auch die wahrnehmung beeinflusst und
weil es ein zeichen für offenheit und
toleranz und für gleichberechtigung ist
wir kommen gleich zur frage nummer drei
bei 310 fragen wer von euch ist dafür
dass in öffentlichen institutionen
genderspezifische sprachen also zum
beispiel auch in schulen oder in
universitäten eingeführt und zwar
verpflichtend eingeführt wird
heute sind deutlich bei leihen weil sie
sind deutlich bei ja ich bin
schriftsteller und gehe mit sprache um
und habe einen großen respekt vor der
sprache und sehe jeglichen versuch des
wohn und touristischen eingriffs in
sprache um es mal so zu nennen und um
nichts anderes handelt es sich ja als
respektlos gegenüber der sprache an also
menschen die sagen wir brauchen das
nicht das sind meistens leute die von
diskriminierung nicht betroffen sind die
selbst nicht wissen wie es sich anfühlt
diskriminiert zu werden aufgrund von
sprache wir kommen zu frage nummer vier
dazu eine kurze vorrede um mal beispiele
zu nennen ihr kennt kennt sie alle
bei pippi langstrumpf wurde aus dem
nichts zum beispiel der südsee könig die
mohrenstraße in berlin wird umbenannt
die [ __ ] soße heißt mehr und mehr
paprika soße wir streichen also aktiv
als gesellschaft begriffe aus unserem
wortschatz
jetzt kommt die frage ist das
eliminieren von rassistischen begriffen
ein sinnvolles mittel im kampf gegen
rassismus
[Musik]
die streichung von worten in der
literatur was tatsächlich in erster
linie in kinderliteratur gemacht wird
finde ich problematisch ich selber habe
ein kind das dunkle haut hat und ich
möchte meinem kind die bedeutung des
wortes erklären und nicht die peer group
auf der straße und der erste schritt in
richtung einer gesellschaft mit
diskriminierungsfreier sprache wäre
marginalisierten menschen zuzuhören
menschen die etwa die rassismus erfahren
die sexismus erfahren die trans
friedlichkeit erfahren und nachzufragen
über welche begriffe wollt ihr sprechen
welche begriffe sollten zur verhandlung
stehen und vor allem müssen wir auch
darüber sprechen wie diese menschen sich
selbst bezeichnen müssen und der rest
der gesellschaft muss das bedingungslos
akzeptieren an die gruppe in gelb etwas
mehr als die hälfte der deutschen hat
sich in einer aktuellen umfrage dagegen
ausgesprochen dass in der öffentlichkeit
und in den medien geändert wird nur ein
drittel war dafür wenn aber nun trotzdem
menschen ländern zum beispiel im
öffentlich-rechtlichen empfinden das
manche als bevormundung könnt ihr das
nachvollziehen
ja hieße ich gehe einen schritt vor nein
diese stehen bleiben oder nach hinten
ja ich kann die kritik nachvollziehen
und jetzt aus der erfahrung im job kann
ich auch sagen es sind vor allem nicht
böse gemeint ältere menschen die dort
die das nicht nicht nicht akzeptieren
können oder nicht sehen können
du hast erfahrung im job erwähnt weil du
natürlich bei dem radiosender der heißt
fritz habt ihr das eingeführt und zwar
verpflichtende den nachrichten
eingeführt das geändert wird und der
gegenwind war da der gegenwind war das
war aber auch der provinz der war auch
da ungefähr 50 kräfte war so die
aufteilung später warum bist du nach
hinten gegangen
aus zwei gründen erstens finde ich sehr
schwierig das meer die menschen die in
der vergangenheit sozusagen das privileg
hatten immer so bezeichnet oder
angesprochen zu werden wie sie es
möchten nun sagen wir fühlen uns
bevormundet werden wir sozusagen auf
marginalisierte menschen die in der
vergangenheit diesen luxus nicht hatten
zugehen und ihnen den luxus den sie
vorher hatten auch selber zu sprechen
und zwar so angesprochen zu werden wie
man das möchte und zweitens finde ich es
immer schwierig gewisse bedürfnisse und
gewisse ungerechtigkeiten die auf
sprachlicher ebene in der gesellschaft
geschehen von mehrheiten abhängig zu
machen weil ja ja die mehrheit der
menschen in deutschland sind zum
beispiel weiß und da wundert es mich
nicht dass sie zum beispiel nicht in der
selben art und weise von rassistischer
sprache betroffen sind wir es
infizierten menschen deswegen finde ich
sehr sehr schwierig solche fragen auch
der gerechtigkeit an mehrheiten und
minderheiten festzumachen
ich habe natürlich auch noch eine frage
an euch an die gruppe die gerade auf den
grünen feldern steht es gibt tatsächlich
mehrere studien zuletzt eine große
metastudie in schweden die nahelegen
dass gender gerechte sprache in diesem
fall war es gender gerechter sprache
durchaus einfluss auf gender gerechtes
denken haben kann
also scheint es doch angebracht nicht
nur gesellschaft und haltung sondern
auch die sprache aktiv zu verändern wenn
er sagen würde die a
dann geht ihr bitte einem schritt vor
und wenn ihr sagt dass er völlig absurd
dann bitte nach
das kann man so nicht geht nicht geht
nicht darum
sobald die studie auf die du ansprichst
eine studie zu gender neutraler sprache
es geht darum ein gender neutrales also
ein weder nach
münchen noch weibchen unterscheiden
diesem grund haben wir nach dem
schwedischen diese unterscheidung genau
das heißt das ist genau das gegenteil
von dem was wir in deutschland machen
das halte ich für richtig wenn wir das
tun würden
wer ich drüben bei denen aber das machen
wir nicht und deswegen aber unabhängig
von dieser differenzierung die absolut
richtig ist geht es ja durchaus darum
dass sprache einfluss auf denken hat ich
bin dagegen weil ich glaube nicht weil
ich glaube dass sprache keinen einfluss
hat ich glaube sprache hat ein wenn auch
ein sehr klein aber das was sie tun ist
einfach die falsche richtung
ich glaube das denken vor allen dingen
die sprache beeinflusst das heißt wenn
ich überzeugt werde ich jenna zum
beispiel die länder weil ich und ich
setze mich damit auseinander es ist
alles im fluss und merken dass ich das
hier wird es umständlich hier konnte man
neuen begriff machen
aber der punkt ist tatsächlich zu sagen
die gendern jetzt oder die benutzten
andere begriffe und dadurch ändert sich
die einstellungen dadurch ändert sich ja
nicht nur durch die worte ändert sich ja
nicht die einstellung sondern wenn sie
die bewusst nutzen und das was dahinter
ist eben auch nutzen will heißen die
akzeptanz und den respekt vor den
menschen die vorher im benachteiligt
waren ich würde mich auch interessieren
was ihr davon haltet wie viel einfluss
hat die sprache eurer meinung nach hat
sie viel oder wenig einfluss darüber
werden wir sicherlich noch weiter
streiten
eure meinung ist natürlich weiterhin
gefragt wenn wir gerade bei die sind
marius und zur nächsten frage über gehen
die frage wäre bei dir gab es
situationen oder wann war die letzte
situation wo du dich allein durch
sprache verletzt gefühlt hast bei mir
ist es tatsächlich dass ich bin nicht
bin ich so schnell verletzt vor durch
sprache weil ich mich so wahnsinnig viel
damit auseinandersetze und relativ viel
durchgehen lassen meistens sind es nicht
die worte sondern das sind die leute die
die worte sagen die die auch mit einer
aggression sagen oder die mit einer
unterschwelligen aggressionen sagen
sticks and stones wohl break my bones
bett james will never heard mich stimmt
nicht 100 prozent aber die die
laufrichtung stimmt für mich aber gäbe
es zum beispiel einschlägige
rassistische wörter das n-wort von denen
du dich dann in einer von einer person
nicht diskriminiert führen würde
beim n wort also das was jeder der mich
kennt das nutze ich in meiner literatur
auch in seinem aktuellen buch ich nutze
ist weil ich glaube wenn ich eine
geschichte erzählen wo ich eine soziale
milieu darstelle
da wo ich das problem mit diesem wort
darstellen will und nur ein wort sagen
oder wie in extras mm
dann nehme ich die schärfe dieses wortes
komplett raus und kommen so eine formale
komische geschichte und ich glaube dass
wir aufpassen müssen dass wir wörter
nicht zu sehr zu waffen machen also dass
wir die hochstilisieren weil ich nenne
das gerne in voldemort effekt wenn ich
die ganze zeit n wort sagen dann ist es
der dessen name nicht genannt werden
darf das heißt das wort wird immer
größer es wird immer aggressiver es wird
immer mächtiger
und ich glaube dass wir den wörtern auch
macht nehmen können und vielleicht
wieder hingehen und überlegen die
haltung die dahinter steckt die die
macht mir probleme
das ist ja auch das nachvollziehen
entschuldigen wenn ich aber so wollte
man dort drüben hören was ihr so sagt
also ich bin jetzt wieder bei dem
begriff mohrenstraße beispielsweise also
ich finde es sehr gut ich fände es sehr
gut wenn wir das als mahnmal irgendwie
nicht auslöschen sondern irgendwie dann
auch anschließend darüber aufklären
können was das was dieses wort macht
warum das ein kompliziertes ein
schwieriges wort das in der gesellschaft
und nicht immer nur alles weg
wegradieren dann passiert nämlich genau
das was du sagst dass es dann noch
mächtiger noch gefährlicher für die
gesellschaft wird aber würdest was
würdest du von adolf hitler straße
erhalten
ja das würde ich war bevor wir deswegen
genau aber es gibt ja ganz spezifische
räume wo diese aufarbeitung arbeit
geleistet wird
also es ist ja zum beispiel in
deutschland nicht verboten den namen
adolf hitler in den mund zu nehmen aber
wir wissen ja trotzdem auch aus einer
gewissen geschichtlichen erfahrung dass
es gewisse räume gibt wo du es nicht
angebracht ist wo wir eine gewisse
geschichte der gewalt der
diskriminierung auch dass antisemitismus
fortschreiben würden wenn wir jetzt
einfach eine arbeit fiddler straße
behalten würde in deutschland das ist
einfach nicht geht aber in dem fall aber
auch wenn wir zum beispiel die emsstraße
und so weiter und sofort streichen heißt
das ja nicht dass ich aus dem
kollektiven gedächtnis gestrichen ist
sondern dass wir andere räume etablieren
wo menschen auf augenhöhe miteinander
ins gespräch kommen und diese die die
auseinandersetzung damit es ja dann
nicht ausgelöscht
ich habe angst vor einer größeren also
dass man selbst sensibler wird also ich
kann sagen ich bin jüdisches gibt
der zweiten deutschen staat eine
judengasse einen juden brunnen einen
irgendwas und die haben alle keine
schöne geschichte und ich bin so froh
dass meine leute das nicht diskutieren
dass ich nicht wenn ich daran vorbei
gehe frage mich frage verletzt mich das
jetzt ist das jetzt schlimm für mich
sein mein gott ist hat die judengasse
interviewte ist doch ist doch kein
erstmal kein schimpfwort oder bin ich da
falsch herr [ __ ] ist definitiv und ganz
klar rassistisch kommentiert und juden
nicht von daher ist das natürlich ein
riesen unterschied
das ist natürlich auch ein kultureller
weiter ja aber würde weil die diese zum
beispiel die geschichte der straße
genauso wie die geschichte von einer von
mohrengasse das ist ganz schwierig
selbst wenn ich dann schildchen drunter
machen wir waren wir waren letztes jahr
waren wir in berlin und haben uns
bestimmte straßen die nach irgendwelchen
leuten benannt sind
da sind so kleine schildchen darunter
genauso wie irgendwelche denkmäler das
bringt nichts da drunter zu schreiben
der war übrigens auch total böse
wir werden noch weiter das geschehen
aber torsten ist die ganze zeit am zug
wenn ich das ich will eigentlich verrät
ja ich hab schon eher faden verloren
aber ich glaube es mündet doch in der
sackgasse wenn jede soziologische gruppe
1 in einer gesellschaft ihre eigene
verletztheit nach haut nach draußen
kehrt und demzufolge straßennamen
verändert werden müssen bestimmte
bestimmte begriffe in büchern nicht mehr
vorkommen dürfen oder dergleichen also
ich finde es gut wenn es dann diskurs
gibt aber ebenso muss man dann natürlich
aufpassen dass nicht dieses diese diese
diktatur des selbst verletzt sein
ob waltet also damit ist auch den
sogenannten in anführungszeichen gesetzt
opfergruppen nicht genutzt als du
sprichst dich er dagegen aus die
mohrenstraße umzubenennen oder den mega
könig aus pippi langstrumpf zu streichen
das riecht ja auf jeden fall also das
ist ja das sind glaube ich die sachen
aber ich bin ich bin in beiden fällen
dagegen aber ich kann mir vorstellen
dass man sozusagen wenn man wenn man im
unterricht ist dass man das begleitend
diskutiert oder dass man nach
fortschreibt oder ein vorwort aber ich
kann nicht in diesen in diesem kontext
eingreifen der historisch ist also
dieses geschichtliche denken zu
verlernen was sie gefahr dessen mit sich
was die gefahr ist halte ich halte ich
für schwierig meint es ja es ist
opfergruppen damit nicht geholfen ich
finde
die opfergruppen wissen selber ziemlich
genau womit ihnen geholfen ist er vor
gruppen in anführungszeichen gesetzt
ja aber so oder so ich meine ersten da
sind auch zweitens finde ich den
dahinterliegenden geschichts oder
kulturbegriffs begriff sehr sehr
schwierig weil wir sind uns doch alle
einig dass kultur etwas mensch gemacht
das ist dass sich verändert also wenn
man sich zum beispiel die bibel anschaut
die gibt es auch ein sehr vielen
verschiedenen auslegung es gibt auch
eine bibel in gerechter sprache also
sich dem dann zu verschließen und zu
sagen also entweder passiert das
irgendwie organisch so ganz zufällig mal
gucken dann gleiten wir vielleicht alle
mensch erkennt ja auch das kultur etwas
mensch gemacht es ist dass man auch
dementsprechend in gewisse kontexte
setzen kann anpassen kann ein gewisse
bedürfnisse
ich würde nicht nicht böse sein aber du
sagst die die opfergruppen und ja die
sollen nicht so und sagt der weiße mann
ja das ist richtig wenn man wenn man ist
das privileg hat niemals auf dieser
seite zu stehen ist das kein problem
und übrigens fast historische sachen
angeht kinder können sich historisch
denken
das heißt ich muss das als vater machen
ich bin sogar auch dagegen ich bin
dagegen den dieser ziemlich raus zu
streichen sollte nichtigem einer
dunkelhäutigen tochter möchte ich
erklären was es mit dem wort [ __ ] auf
sich hat und diese möglichkeit wird mir
definitiv genommen in dem moment wo das
überall raus gestrichen wird und ich
plötzlich meinem kind eine völlig
absurde schöne welt voller blumen
liefert jetzt plädiert du also dafür für
eine kontextualisierung du würdest die
wörter weiter bestehen lassen aber dann
mit seiner tochter straße aber ja eben
nicht in der straße im buch ja weil du
dann die die eigene macht darüber hast
in welchem kontext du das verwenden und
tausche ich das aus meiner tochter 6 so
aber sobald ich merke jetzt kann ich es
an bringen jetzt kommt ein historisches
denken auf möchte ich das besprechen und
das soll nicht die peergroup auf der
straße
julia du bist gründerin von trans kids
unter anderem engagierst dich viel bist
man kann nicht als aktivisten auch
bezeichnen viele trans menschen und
nicht binäre menschen fühlen sich ja
tatsächlich diskriminiert und
ausgeschlossen wenn es immer nur
weibliche oder männliche änderungen gibt
was bedeutet also in deinen augen jetzt
zum beispiel das gender sternchen
das gender ständchen soll eigentlich
alle inkludieren die sich unter einem
bestimmten oder oder die sich nicht
einer bestimmten identität zu ordnen
möchten
also wenn ich lehrer sternchen innen
schreibe beispielsweise dann sind da
sowohl die lehrer die die männlichen
lehrer die weiblichen lehrerin aber auch
die nicht binären personen mit gemeint
also das gender sternchen das sorgt für
uns einfach viel mehr für sichtbarkeit
und was diese menschen nicht vergessen
werden würdest du dir wünschen dass eine
breite masse das sternchen zum beispiel
auch verwendet ich finde es gut wenn
also menschen in leitungspositionen in
einem einer firma in dem unternehmen
oder auch die bundesregierung
beispielsweise in behördlichen
einrichtungen wenn die das verpflichtend
einsetzen würden ja mario scalzo
nachvollziehen
ich versuche gerade nachzuvollziehen er
jetzt wie man das zum beispiel im radio
es gibt glaube ich doch keine akustische
form nicht es gibt auch nur eine
schriftliche form oder also man sagt ja
nicht lehrer sternchen innen oder naja
das gender ständchen an sich also in der
schreib form gibt es schon länger das
wird immer mehr an das ist ja nicht nur
bei uns so also auch wenn ich briefe
e-mails oder so schreibe schreibt sich
einfach wahnsinnig gut und hat eine gute
bedeutet wie du gerade gesagt hat stets
hat alle geschlechter mit ein
das ist ja der sinn dahinter aber es hat
noch nie jemand probiert es zu sprechen
und es war mal die kritik das
funktioniert auch im radio nicht dass
zum ausprobieren
wir haben es dann ausprobierten haben
gemerkt doch das ist gar nicht so
kompliziert und man muss da gar keine
riesige pause sprechen betont dass ein
bisschen mehr und mit zwei mal üben
funktioniert das gut ihr habt öffnet als
öffentlich rechtlicher sender
entschieden wir wollen das machen weil
wir das aufgrund abc sinnvoll finden
es gibt menschen davon haben wir vorhin
schon gesprochen die nicht nur angst
davor haben sondern die sich bevormundet
fühlen was hältst du von der einführung
des gesprochenen gender sternchens im
radio ich halte da nicht so viel davon
aber ich würde im sinne von leben und
leben lassen immer sagen ihr sonst so
machen also ich finde das in ordnung für
mich wird überhaupt erst ein problem
daraus wenn es im zusammenhang mit
oktroyieren geschieht wenn bestimmte
dinge vorgegeben beziehungsweise
angeordnet werden und leute sich danach
richten müssen
also das hat mit meinem verständnis von
demokratie und miteinander leben und da
mag vielleicht meine ddr herkunft eine
rolle spielen das gebe ich gerne zu
hat das wenig zu tun hast du denn das
gefühl dass das ist in diese richtung
geht also hat zum beispiel angst davor
dass jetzt irgendein verlag zu dir sagt
dass buch nehmen wir so nicht weil du
hast nicht geändert ich musste zwei
sachen auseinander halten also ich habe
keine angst davor aber ich bin jetzt
auch kein typisches beispiel vielleicht
also ich sag mal so wenn wenn in
universitäten oder kulturellen
institutionen so etwas vorgegeben wird
dann kann kann ich muss ich das nicht
berücksichtigen also ich mach das
weiterhin so wie ich es für richtig
halte
aber ich weiß aus der beobachtung und
aus vielen gesprächen dass zum beispiel
akademische mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiterinnen angestellte im
verwaltungsbereich das auf sich nehmen
und dieses gender sternchen verwenden
und groll empfinden und das finde ich
schade weil da geht etwas nach hinten
los und damit hat man ein ein effekt den
ich auch aus der ddr kenne und bei uns
in unserer gesellschaft wird zunehmend
beobachtet
also es gibt einen reden in der
öffentlichkeit und es gibt einen reden
im vertrauten raum oder gar unter vier
augen also gibt da geht mehr und mehr
durch gegeneinander und das finde ich
sehr schade und auch gefährlich und hab
ich dich richtig verstanden du glaubst
doch wenn man läuft gefahr wenn man
jetzt ändern zb verpflichtend an
universitäten einführt oder eingeführt
hat dass man der spaltung der
gesellschaft damit vorschub leistet habe
ich das recht absolut also wenn man das
passt pro toto nimmt das ist mein das
ist das ist jetzt keine these das ist
das was ich beobachte und aus gesprächen
sozusagen weiß ja reaktion thorsten du
hast du eben du hast du eben gesagt wenn
jemand verlangt so und so angesprochen
werden zu wollen dann würdest du das
auch dem wunsch auch nachkommt wenn eine
universität sagt bei uns dabei alles
geändert warum kommt zudem noch nicht
nach weil die universität kein
individuum ist sondern sondern eine
institution das ist das problem darin
wenn was passiert dann wenn jetzt bei
euch ist ich weiß momentan ist das nicht
der fall weil es ja auch ein wunsch der
redaktion war zu gendern auch im radio
was ist denn wenn irgendjemand
irgendwann ein radiomoderator oder
moderatorin kommt gesagt nee ich habe da
keine lust mitzumachen wird er dann
gefeuert oder diejenige wir haben es ja
nicht an der moderation wir haben sie in
den nachrichten verpflichten ein
also nachrichtenmoderator oder
moderatorin gefeiert wir haben jemanden
der der dagegen ist das war auch ein
wunsch unserer kolleginnen das halt zu
machen also wenn wir landerechte sprache
weiter vorantreiben wollen finde ich
dass es auch gewisse vorgaben geben
sollte
die vielleicht erstmal ungewohnt sind
geht immer davon aus dass es eine
geschlossene geschlossenes interessen
marginalisierten gruppen gibt dass die
marginalisierten alle dasselbe wollen
aber das ist natürlich nicht so also
wenn jetzt an dieser universität die
julia gerade in den raum gestellt hat
verpflichtendes ländern eingeführt wird
eingeführt und ich will nicht geändert
werden was machst du dann wenn es auf
universitäts ebene ein fürst sagst du
trittst eine entscheidung für alle
betroffenen so julia die frage war
eigentlich ich würde also wenn eine
universität oder egal welche
einrichtungen ein unternehmen eine
universität eine behörde das für sich
einführt dann steht es jedem frei ob er
sich dem anschließt ob er der vision
dieser firma folgt oder ob er sich in
anderen job sucht es ist gut dass du der
heißt du wirst die leute mitgehen lassen
ich weil ich sagen ich möchte aber nicht
geändert wird
haushalt aber ich meine flasche grappa
und auch vom generischen maskulinum
angesprochen und ihr könnt es ja auch
sagen okay es gibt ein sehr großes
interesse von natürlich will ich auch
nicht sagen dass marginalisierte
menschen eine homogene gruppe sind
natürlich ganz und gar nicht und
innerhalb dieser gruppen werden ja auch
seit jahren jahrzehnten unterschiedliche
diskussion nach unterschiedlichen
begriffen geführt aber wenn es so zu
sagen da eine laute stimme gibt die sagt
uns ist es wichtig als zum beispiel
nicht binäre menschen dass wir zumindest
mit diesem sender sternchen mit
inkludiert werden in die sprache warum
ist es dann für binäre menschen wie uns
zum beispiel frauen und männer und so
weiter und so fort dann plötzlich ein
problem das wir doch wieder nur mit
gemeint sind weil in der im generischen
maskulinum sind wir ja auch nur mit
gemeint wenn du eine generische form ist
hast dann ist jeder gleich gebaut das ja
das ziel aber dann muss ganz kurz machte
julia was sagen ich möchte gleich noch
muss man sagen wenn jetzt der deutsche
staat verpflichtend gegen gesetzestexte
soll ich dann einfach deutschland
verlassen ist dass die ist es die
auflage so sucht der halten andere ich
erkläre über sollen
die andere seite verlass wenn ich wenn
ich als transaktion mich irgendwo
bewerben möchte bei einer firma und ich
sehe auf der webseite dass die kein
keine lgbt abteilung an der börse die
abteilung dann bewerbe ich mich dort
nicht wenn ich aber bei sap see die
haben sogar eigene richtlinien für die
traditions- phase dann ist das die erste
firma bei der ich mich bewerben würde
aber bei den anderen da bin ich mir
einfach nicht sicher ob ich dort gut
aufgenommen bin ob ich dort überhaupt
richtig bin was er werden kann so aber
man muss glaube ich mal ein bisschen
sortieren also gibt gibt die sprache die
hat sich über jahrhunderte entwickelt zu
dieser sprache gehört das generische
maskulinum ob wir wollen oder nicht
patrick hat gewohnt haben immer und es
immer noch tun dass er ja aber lasst uns
also ich meine dass der grund das ist
der grund er gut verliert dann dann
kommen dann haben wir jetzt ist es also
natürlich auch teil des patriarchen also
ich meine wenn hat es so eine keule die
daraus gezogen wird dann können wir uns
alle nach hause gehen wir haben schlicht
überhaupt nicht es ist nicht weiter nele
hat einen vorschlag der der deswegen
interessant ist weil er nicht so oft
ende zumindest in der öffentlichen
diskussion aufs tableau kommt du sagst
gender also gendern in der sprache die
leute die dagegen sind weil sich das so
schwierig spricht zum beispiel sagst du
käse du bist aus anderen gründen dagegen
warum weil ich die art wie wir es in
deutschland gerade machen
diskriminierend empfinden weil wir
permanent auf geschlechter verweisen und
zwar auf etwas was wir also ein
vorgestelltes biologisches geschlecht
weil du fragst mich nicht vorher nele
duman frau sondern du gehst davon aus
und dann bezeichnet oder du vielleicht
jetzt nicht aber dann bezeichnet mich
der andere als schriftstellerin sagt
also in der weno meines berufes ist es
entscheidend dass ich eine frau bin
wenn wir das mit irgendeiner anderen
kategorie machen würden also wenn wir
zum beispiel feststellen würden okay
auch noch jüdisch auch noch schwarz und
sagen würden okay ich bin jetzt die
stärke der schriftsteller jude würde
jeder sofort sagen bot das aber
antisemitisch dass wenn wir das gleiche
mit geschlechtern
denken wir auf einmal es wäre für die
gleichstellung und ich glaube das
gegenteil ist es führt dazu dass man das
geschlecht immer wieder neu denken muss
und da glaube ich dass wir sozusagen das
tatsächlich unsere sprache unser denken
beeinflusst nämlich insofern als dass
wir immer und immer wieder gezwungen
sind über geschlecht nachzudenken das
heißt du würdest auch sagen
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel ist würde
ich sagen das würde angela merkel auch
sagen angela merkel bezeichnet sich
selbst 1992 wunderschöne rede gestern
noch mal angeguckt als ich bin minister
ich bin realist das ding ist wenn angela
merkel bundeskanzler gewesen wäre
also hat von uns allen als bundeskanzler
bezeichnet worden wäre dann gäbe es
heute 16 jährige kinder die beim wort
bundeskanzler nur an eine frau denken
können weil sie einfach nie etwas
anderes erlebt haben also für mich ist
die bessere lösung lasst uns unsere
gesellschaft ändern und lasst uns eine
generische form verwenden und die dann
auffüllen mit dem was in der realität
passiert überzeugt sich das kochen nähe
ist überzeugt nicht weil es in der
realität ja nicht passiert es hört sich
fast schon so an als würden wir sonst in
unserer sprache nicht ändern also wenn
du das generische maskulin und benutzt
denn dass du ja auch also wir können ja
nicht nichts ändern in unserer sprache
und du hast ja eben auch angela merkel
als sie bezeichnen das heißt du hast du
ja auch gleichzeitig einerseits als
bundeskanzler also men nicht gesammelt
und dann wieder sie gesagt also ich
stimme zu dass es ein grundlegendes
problem in unserer sprache gibt aber ich
finde man kann nicht so einfache
lösungen sagen die ok wir sehen jetzt
ich sage nur noch bundeskanzler und dann
gendern die aber nicht weil dann ist es
ja eh alles generisch maskulinum also
unsere ganze sprache ist ja geändert und
wir müssen ja von da ausgehend uns
fragen okay wie kriegen wir das hin das
ist möglich mögliche rechnen beide total
dasselbe ich glaube wir wollen beide
eine nicht diskriminierende sprache was
glaube ich bei uns beiden bedeutet wir
wollen nicht immer auf geschlecht
verweisen und die frage ist wie kommen
wir da hin also mein beispiel immer das
wort fräulein und das wort frau bis vor
60 jahren war fräulein die
unverheiratete frau und frau war die
verheiratete frau
jetzt hat man das wort fräulein
weggelassen und jetzt denkt niemand bei
dem wort frau mehr mit okay die ist
verheiratet wenn ich sagt frau polaczek
oder wenn jemand
frau polaczek denke niemand ok wo ist wo
es herr pollatschek das denken wir nicht
mehr weil durch das weglassen der
trennung die kategorie sich gewartet hat
und ich meine hoffnung ist wenn wir
andere formen weglassen dann wird sich
die existierende form anpassen und jetzt
bin ich total gut hob in meiner
vorstellung das weiß ich ich möchte
gerne die gerechte welt oder zumindest
erstmal wenig möchte die gerechte welt
und die gerechte sprache wäre schon auch
cool ich möchte die gerechte welt und
ich möchte sie gerne noch erleben und
dann bin ich pragmatisch ich möchte
lieber dass es sender neutralen
toiletten gibt als dass wir lange
diskussion darüber führen und ich sehe
in der deutschen bahn passiert ja schon
aber das ist offensichtlich die lösung
also ich gucke mir an wo passiert schon
was funktioniert schon und das setzt
sich dann durch
einfach weil ich es noch erleben möchte
also julia zumindest ist jetzt keinen
schritt vorgegangen
das heißt sie offenbar nicht so
überzeugt ihr dürft natürlich euch
weiter bewegen wenn ihr wollt du gehst
aber so einen halben schritt vor warum
ich bin anderer meinung was das
generierte generische maskuline mehr
betrifft ich finde das ist so ein
historisch beladener begriff wir können
diese patriarchale beladung nicht mehr
davon abwälzen ich finde
der begriff wird es nicht bringen ich
stimme auch zu dass sozusagen die wir
jetzt im moment ländern mit einfach dem
sternchen das dann plötzlich alle
geschlechts identitäten inkludieren soll
dass es auch nicht die endgültige lösung
ist weil es halt viel weil das sternchen
das dass man die anhängt und dann so ja
okay wir haben jetzt alles nur weil
unsere sprache ist jetzt gerächt also
ich sehe dass sozusagen als ein werkzeug
auf dem weg zu einer gerechteren sprache
in der vielleicht und da bin ich ein
bisschen bei nele vielleicht diese
ganzen ja geschlechtsspezifischen
endungen irgendwann gar nicht mehr
gebraucht werden und nicht mehr nötig
seien an sich findest du die
argumentation schlüssig eine quasi
insgesamt neutrale zur sprache zu
verwenden das ist für mich nicht neutral
also neutral ist für mich wenn wirklich
alle tatsächlich inkludiert werden und
nicht andere hinten runterfallen
aber das wäre ja ihrem sinne wäre das so
wenn man sagt bundeskanzler ist jeder
mitgemeint für mich nicht
bislang ist das wäre ihre forderung dass
das überhaupt schon weiß natürlich die
männliche form ist deswegen ist es nur
eine behauptung gut
passt für mich nicht zusammen okay aber
es ist doch ein sprachwandel prozess
also ich sage das ist ja der name
kartoffelsalat sprachwandel nicht wir
behalten das und denken uns was anderes
dabei aber sprachwandel passiert genau
weil wird die worte behalten und uns was
anderes dabei hätten das ist der größte
teil des sprach wandels ist dass frau
die bedeutung geändert hat frau heißt
jetzt auch unverheiratete frau das ist
ein sprachen wir haben das den begriff
behalten frau für verheiratete und haben
die bedeutung geändert so funktioniert
der großteil unseres sprachwandel dann
lasst uns einmal lasst uns mal kurz für
eine abstimmung per per schritt machen
damit wir das mal klar kriegen weil ich
glaube die argumente sind einigermaßen
auf den tisch wollen wir uns also in
zukunft auf eine gender neutrale sprache
anstatt auf eine genderspezifische
sprache einigen wer ja sagt geht schritt
vor werde nein sagt bleibt steht da war
ich im moment also müssen wir jetzt
gerade weil deine den vorfall so dass
grund selbst sagt wir reden nicht über
das generische maskulinum sondern
grundlage aber damit da würde ich sofort
nein sagen ja okay wir reden erst mal
vom grundsatz natürlich grundsätzlich 69
nimmer da warst du schon im jeden fall
dann bin ich ja schon hier
wir sind so ein bisschen in der
möglichen kompromissfindung aber es gibt
ja einen vorschlag der stadt jetzt auch
nicht von mir aber manche menschen
fordern nämlich einen nationalen sprach
rat bestehend aus allen
gesellschaftlichen gruppierungen nicht
vom gesetzgeber vorgegeben der sich eben
damit beschäftigt ob und wie wir unsere
sprache modernisieren können dann würden
solche diskussionen eben nicht mehr nur
hier stattfinden oder auf twitter
sondern in einem gesellschaftlich
legitimierten rat was haltet ihr davon
ich kann nicht nur was du bist schon ich
würde natürlich also das ist jetzt sehr
sehr noch sehr grob skizziert man muss
ja auch nicht de oder auch genau es geht
um die idee ich würde gerne noch einen
dritten punkt anmerken und abzufragen ob
wir uns einig sind oder nicht wer sich
durch eine anrede oder bezeichnung
herabgewürdigt fühlt oder verletzt
sollte die entscheidung darüber treffen
dürfen wie mensch angesprochen oder
bezeichnet werden möchte können wir uns
darauf einigen
also wenn ich mich angegriffen fühle
sage ich ich möchte so bezeichnet werden
und das ist das möchte was war das noch
nicht
es geht ja nur um wissen kommen seiner
das ist ja möglich
wir reden von selbstbestimmung aber
nicht dass irgendwelche formen
da waren wir ja ja ja das ist ja genau
also in dieses bild was ich jetzt gerade
gezeigt hat ihr steht sagte freunde das
ist spiegelt natürlich nicht unbedingt
den verlauf der diskussion wieder
bitte bleibt auch bei uns bleibt auch in
unserer mitte thorsten wir brauchen
jeden mann in dem sprache ja wenn es den
gleisen
wenn es den geben sollte also wir haben
das gesehen wir stehen zwar jetzt alle
ziemlich nah beieinander aber es gibt
die differenzen sind klar als die
diskussion da genauso emotional wie ich
es erwartet habe von allen seiten und
ich glaube dass wir mit dem ziel total
gleich waren alle also auch die grüne
seite aber jeder hat einen anderen weg
dorthin
und der war schon sehr unterschiedlich
ich habe ja unterm strich niemand
wahrgenommen der diese länder
sprachregelung nicht als ein gewisses
übel oder sehen würde also jedenfalls
weit entfernt das non plus ultra zu sein
als etwas das auf dem weg ist und das
finde ich ok also das ist eine
gemeinsame position mit der kann man gut
leben glaube ich finde auch noch mal da
wo wir sozusagen die diskussion beendet
haben nicht nur wie kann eine
genderspezifische fürsprache aussehen
sondern auch vielleicht irgendwann
wirklich gender neutrale sprache und
dass auf der ganzen ebene unserer
sprache ich finde da kann man auf jeden
fall weiter gehen und sich weiter
gedanken machen wir freuen uns mit euch
zu diskutieren hier könnt ihr unseren
kanal abonnieren
hier oben gibt es ein weiteres video zum
thema und hier eine weitere folge 13
fragen
ja